will unbedingt eine weitere gäste in
einen weiteren gast in der sendung
begrüßen melanie brinkmann nämlich sie
ist uns aus braunschweig zugeschaltet
verbringt man sie haben mit ihren
kollegen vom helmholtz zentrum und
anderen wissenschaftlern der politik
noch viel härtere maßnahmen an geraten
nämlich eine no go it strategie also
eine neue strategie was halten sie
eigentlich von diesen maßnahmen zu
glauben sie daran dass wir am 14
dass er jetzt alle gesagt bekommen eine
50er incidents haben ist das realistisch
ich glaube das ist das was sehr
schwierig ist in der kommunikation die
zurzeit betrieben wird dass wir daten
sagen am soundsovielten schauen wir mal
und das weckt natürlich hoffnung und die
menschen gucken auf dieses datum und
wenn dann die ministerpräsidenten wieder
zusammensitzen und diskutieren und
entscheiden wir können noch nicht weiter
lockern wir müssen sogar vielleicht das
gegenteil durchführen geboten wegen der
bedrohung durch neue virusvarianten dann
ist das nicht gut für den einzelnen
menschen der dadurch natürlich immer
wieder enttäuscht wird deshalb würde ich
oder habe ich vorgeschlagen zusammen mit
wissenschaftlern einer sehr
interdisziplinären gruppe von
wissenschaftlern dass man ein
langfristiges ziel formuliert und es
wäre glaube ich deutlich besser zu sagen
wenn wir ein gewisses ziel erreicht
haben und das ziel kann man in einer
instanz ausdrücken von 1 kann man eine
gewisse zahl benutzen
dann hilft es ungemein denn dann weiß
man selber okay dann wird das erreicht
haben dann können wir gewisse bereiche
wieder öffnen oder gewisse maßnahmen
lockern und ich glaube das wäre deutlich
leichter in der kommunikation auch
menschen wirklich mitzunehmen
dann muss ja schon sagen wir sind seit
vielen monaten wirklich sehr belasteten
in der gesellschaft die restaurants
geschlossen die kultur leitet eltern
sind im home office und verzweifeln und
den kindern und den möchte ich ganz
schön ist es sehr bitter was gerade
passiert für unsere gesamte gesellschaft
und ich glaube es wäre zwingend
notwendig
zu sagen wir möchten ein gewisses ziel
erreichen und dann kann ich menschen
auch wieder mitnehmen und das hätte ich
mir deutlich gewünscht und ich möchte
auch betonen dass unsere strategie zwar
erstmal sehr hart klingt eine null cobit
strategie also wir wollen nur fälle aber
ich möchte betonen dass ist das ziel es
ist ein ziel auf das wir hinarbeiten
und dafür brauchen wir nicht unbedingt
schärfere maßnahmen oder immer weitere
maßnahmen sondern wir müssen die
maßnahmen die wir haben einfach
effizienter umsetzen wir müssen besser
kommunizieren warum wir gewisse dinge
tun wo wir besser infektionen und wie
wir besser infektionen verhindern können
denn wir müssen ja gar nicht unbedingt
kontakte per se reduzieren wir müssen
die kontakte reduzieren wo infektionen
stattfinden und das müssen wir besser
umsetzt absoluter ist noch mal die frage
verbringt man kann man tatsächlich sagen
es war eine richtige argumentation jetzt
bei den schulen weiter konsequent zu
sein und eigentlich bis zum 14 2
schließen zu wollen mit der begründung
auch diese mutation sei gefährlich für
kinder oder muss man das nicht
eigentlich schon wieder zurückziehen und
sagen man weiß es nicht es ist eben eine
noch nicht klare lage weil wir auch viel
zu wenig ahnung von also außer dem
exponentiellen wachstum natürlich viel
zu wenig ahnung haben wohin die mutation
nun eigentlich am ende dann gehen sie
wird sich durchsetzen aber wo besonders
wissen wir das schon
also die daten aus england und auch aus
anderen ländern zeigen dass dieses virus
die b 11 7 variante infektiöser ist sie
verbreitet sich also sehr schnell in der
bevölkerung und das ist ein großes
risiko denn das bedeutet dass wir es mit
einem neuen man könnte fast sagen mit
einem neuen virus zu tun haben denn es
hat andere eigenschaften ist schneller
geworden was im umkehrschluss heißt das
die maßnahmen die wir jetzt gerade
ergreifen noch nicht einmal mehr
ausreichen würden um dieses virus unter
kontrolle zu bekommen und deshalb müssen
wir jetzt und sehr anstrengen zu
verhindern dass dieses diese variante
oder auch eine der anderen varianten die
es auch noch gibt hier fuß fassen
und da ist es so wenn wir das tut als
mutter von drei kindern wichtig wirklich
jeden hebel zu ziehen den wir gerade
haben aber wie frau schwesig auch gerade
sagte wir müssen in alle bereiche der
gesellschaft gucken
jeder muss für sich noch mal schauen wo
kann ich kontakte wo es zu infektionen
kommen kann reduzieren jeder arbeitgeber
aber auch jeder im privaten bereich
es ist zum beispiel schlecht
kommuniziert worden dass eine familie
kontakt haben kann mit einer weiteren
person da muss man klar kommunizieren
dass es gar nicht um diese diese zahl
geht es geht um konstante kontakte und
die sollten möglichst klein gehalten
werden klein gehalten werden also es
macht keinen sinn die regel würde ja
bedeuten ich kann mich an einem tag mit
20 personen treffen wenn es immer
einzeln ist und das ist gerade keine
gute idee und das muss man einfach noch
besser erklären und kommunizieren ob ich
wir sind noch mal beim ortner noch
mitnehmen wir menschen mitnehmen
wir sind noch mal beim ordnen frage
nummer eins ist die nach dem beraterstab
herr braun der die kanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten berät da hat sich
das ist kolportiert die spd zum beispiel
klaus stöhr gewünscht das ist auch ein
epidemiologe der die whu lange beraten
hat auch mit saas kopf zwei wären warum
solltet ihr nicht mit dabei sein
wir haben uns unmöglich auf einen
bannkreis von von beratern geeinigt es
gab viel viel mehr ideen aber am ende
waren es acht und haben über zweieinhalb
stunden getagt dennoch weitere ging
einfach nicht und man muss in der
politik eins sagen es entsteht jetzt
immer den eindruck besuchen uns
irgendwie unsere wissenschaftler aus je
nachdem welche meinung die gerne hören
und das ist für die politik komplett
inakzeptabel sondern wir müssen ja einen
gewissen logik einer gewissen logik
freundin ist das erste wir haben ein
institut das robert-koch-institut was
für uns die staatliche aufgabe der
infektionskontrolle übernimmt selbst die
über jahre sozusagen die expertise dafür
aufbau und die sind für uns entscheidend
das zweite ist die leopoldina das ist
unsere nationale akademie der
wissenschaften die eben genau die
aufgabe hat wenn die wissenschaft sich
streitet
uns zu sagen was ist die
mehrheitsmeinung dass es die
minderheitsmeinung und dann haben wir
leute wie zum beispiel unser deutsches
zentrum für infektionsforschung oder
unser consozial labor für die
sequenzierung wo es auch um so und die
leute laden wir ein die sind sozusagen
zentral und auch diejenigen die für die
fachgesellschaften sprechen
also das ist ein stück eine objektive
auswahl untersuchen und einfach denn
versuche ich mir mal ein bisschen klarer
also auf der einen seite hat man das
gefühl es gibt menschen wie frau
professor brinkmann mit vielen
unterstützern aus einer internationalen
wissenschaftswelt die sagen eigentlich
müssen wir dieses virus auf null kriegen
und es gibt wenigstens in unserer
wahrnehmung in meiner wahrnehmung eine
verstellbare andere schule die sagt wir
werden mit diesem virus irgendwie leben
müssen das kriegen wir nicht in dieser
zeit in der wir es uns alle wünschen weg
sowie geht die politik jetzt mit diesen
beiden schulen um indem sie die eine
ignorieren und nur die andere einladen
oder indem sie sagen es wäre eigentlich
ganz schlau wenn wir in eine mischung
finden aus einem oder uns verständigen
also ich glaube im grundsatz dass wir
mit dem virus leben müssen das stimmt
erst mal wer aber die impfung wird uns
natürlich massiv helfen die grundfrage
die wir am anfang der epidemie ja auch
diskutiert haben brauchen wir eine
herdenimmunität dadurch dass ein
großteil der bevölkerung die krankheit
durchgemacht und da war das zentrale
argument aus meiner sicht vielleicht
kommen wir ja nie zu einem impfstoff was
bleibt uns denn dann anderes übrig wir
haben als bundesregierung und damals von
anfang an dagegen entschieden auch die
ministerpräsident mit werden gemeinsam
gesagt nein das hat so viele folge
konsequenzen für die für die
möglicherweise die langzeiterkrankungen
für die todesfälle
wir wollen diese infektion bestmöglich
unter kontrolle kriegen und dann hoffen
wir auf einen impfstoff und jetzt haben
wir ja einen impfstoff ohne jetzt sogar
zwei und demnächst drei und vier
dazu kommen wir nach damit ist ja nicht
nein damit ist aber ganz für mich
entscheidend das ist jetzt schon gar
nicht mehr vertretbar finde dass man
sich gedanken darüber macht quasi einen
teil der auch nur ein teil der
bevölkerung zusätzlich und verstärkt dem
virus aus
sie kennen die argumentation
es gibt ja geht um einen besseren schutz
derjenigen die eben besonders betroffen
sind vor allen dingen der alten ich will
auflagen 33 millionen wohl nabu gruppe
in deutschland die werden jetzt mit ffp
zwei masken ausgestattet
aber die vorstellung ich wollen wir sind
bis 1 83 millionen
die vorstellung dass wir dass wir 30
millionen so schützen dass die anderen
sozusagen kein ansteckungsrisiko für die
daten lassen habe ich mir dann die in
heimen sind und da wissen wir dass ein
drittel der menschen die in heimen leben
offensichtlich ein drittel der toten
offensichtlich eben aus heimen stammen
und da könnte man tatsächlich ansetzen
das sind nicht gleich 30 millionen
deutsche sondern es ist eine
überschaubare haben wir aber auch
sozusagen die ganze pandemie durch
wirklich hart daran gearbeitet das ist
für die bundesregierung aber ich muss
jetzt noch mal eingreifen zu einem thema
was vorher von frau schwesig oder von
ihnen herr braun auf dem tisch war was
ich in der formulierung wie sauce
gewählt haben für komplett falsch halte
es vor 48 stunden haben wir die
situation dass wirklich jeder kinder
spaziergang härter durch reguliert war
als die büros der bundesrepublik und
jetzt haben wir eine regelung von der
sie behauptet haben frau schwer sich und
sie auch das sei verbindlich im bereich
home office das sieht nur so aus als sei
es verständlich faktisch ist es gefasst
genauso labberig wie zuvor
da sind sieben acht verschiedene layer
drin die man dann doch wieder
durchbrechen kann weil der arbeitgeber
natürlich behaupten kann das kann hier
gar nicht funktionieren aufgrund abc ob
das sanktioniert wird ob das jemand sagt
das sei mal so dahingestellt
und vor allem geht das nicht für die
entscheidung der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer die hat die bundeskanzlerin
in dem beschluss einfach nur freundlich
gebeten doch bitte das angebot der
arbeitgeber anzunehmen und wenn man
jetzt so ein bisschen weiß wie das
gerade in unternehmen so ist die
vielleicht auch wirtschaftlich nicht so
gut dastehen in diesem moment weil die
pandemie er doch dem einen oder anderen
schadet dann möchte man einfach nicht
die person sein die im montags meeting
sagt ja nee ich bestehe darauf jetzt
aber oft zu machen lieber arbeitgeber
das musst du mir anbieten diese aber
nicht also der der stever muss ist dem
arbeitnehmer anbieten und habe der
arbeitgeber darf es dem arbeitnehmer
nicht vorschreiben und deshalb haben wir
die arbeitnehmer gebeten haben gesagt ja
mit euren arbeitgeber verpflichtet das
euch ein
gebot macht und euch als arbeitnehmer
bitten wir es anzunehmen die müssen sie
es nicht erstreiten sondern sie müssen
vom arbeitgeber nur absolut und wenn sie
mich wollen aus und da ist leben im
grund den man schwierig nachvollziehen
kann wenn sie noch nicht aber nicht
anders möglich muss man leider sagen wir
haben keine rechtliche handhabe als
regierung die arbeitnehmer dazu zu
verpflichten dann auch noch moment das
geht in so vielen anderen ländern
erreichte auge hatte immer schon so viel
spielen arbeitnehmer werden es tun
ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch bei
dem was auf den straßen passiert was man
im netz sieht bei vergleichsweise vielen
leuten jetzt nicht das gefühl dass sie
ausschließlich rational und vernünftig
dass entscheiden was für alle
beteiligten am besten wäre ich habe
schon den eindruck dass inzwischen der
druck so groß ist dass leute sagen die
ich gehe weiter ins büro und wenn das
ein bestimmter prozentsatz tut weil das
gesetzlich möglich ist dann ist die
ganze home office pflicht eben keine
pflicht mehr und ich glaube dass das
genau die labberig kite von maßnahmen
ist wo die leute ausflippen weil die
kindergarten die kindergärten sind zu
die schulen sind zu und trotzdem kommen
sie ins büro und sehen in einem
klitzekleinen meetingraum 17 leute und
alle zwei stunden wird das fenster
aufgemacht und diese inkonsistenz macht
leute wirklich raten damit verwoben
vielleicht damit herr braun noch mal
kurz luft holen kann
haben sie eine idee wie man das auflöst
müsste man noch viel mehr
tatsächlich der wirtschaft auch
vorschreiben was sie arbeitnehmende
anzubieten hat oder geht es nicht weil
wir damit der wirtschaft in viel zu
großen schaden zufügen ich finde die
situation wirklich komplex weil diese
stimmungslage so unterschiedlich ist es
gibt unternehmen das funktioniert das
wunderbar da kann sich der arbeitnehmer
auch darauf verlassen dass er keine
nachteile erleiden muss es gibt
unternehmen da knirscht es total im
getriebe da wird schon der arbeitnehmer
ausgelacht wenn eine maske trägt und
diese vielfalt einzufangen und dann noch
vor dem hintergrund dessen was rechtlich
möglich ist das lässt sich nicht einfach
in ein zwei sätzen lösen aber wir haben
ja noch ein jahr zeit nicht mehr ständig
jetzt mal nicht immer nach hinten
sondern nach vorne gucken dann wäre doch
zum beispiel etwas auch wichtig was ja
in dem neuen referentenentwurf zum
arbeitsschutz auch steht das unter steht
jedenfalls moment noch alle drin alle
technischen möglichkeiten genutzt werden
müssen für den mitarbeiter schutz und
wenn man damit sind wir wieder bei
diesem lied ist und sind bei meinen
geräten also höre meinen aber bei denen
die ich vorgeschlagen habe und den ich
wirklich begeistert so man merkt sich
den roten faden verbrauchen also die
erste frage warum haben wir die
schnelltests noch nicht die die menschen
tatsächlich auch in die aktive rolle
endlich setzten zu sagen okay ich habe
ein positives ergebnis ich informiere
jetzt sofort die menschen die ich
getroffen habe in den letzten zwei tagen
und warum gehen solche geräte nicht am
arbeitsplatz also warum versuchen wir
nicht mit einer art bieber darauf
aufmerksam zu machen wenn man die
distanz unterschreitet also wir haben
für die für die frage der warnung der
anderen ein ganz klares instrument und
dass die korona waren genau das wenn ich
die bei mir trage die anderen tun es
auch dann schaut sie bin ich anderen zu
nahe gekommen
aber im nachhinein und in dem moment
also dass das ist ja in ordnung aber wir
alle können ja einschätzen wie groß ist
unser abstand jetzt man einander und
kommen wir uns so nah und ich finde auch
das haben die menschen gut gelernt die
schwierigkeit ist wenn ich dann wirklich
infiziert bin mich zu erinnern wann er
war ich nahe bei wem und die auch
vollständig zu informieren und dann
vielleicht noch diejenigen die im öpnv
neben wir saßen die ich gar nicht kenne
und das macht die korona waren präzise
und die tatsache dass wir irgendwie
immer alle sein die macht zu wenig und
die sollte sonst noch was tun wir sind
ansonsten ein land das sehr hohen wert
auf datenschutz legt jetzt haben wir mal
eine lösung die wirklich sich auf das
essentielle beschränkt die keine
persönlichen daten aufnimmt und die
genau diese zentrale funktionen erfüllt
und deshalb sollten wir alle gemeinsam
daran arbeiten dass es noch ein paar
mehr leute nutzen
ich glaube hier nutzen es alle und alle
gucken wir auf dieses gerät und kriegen
immer angezeigt also ich auch in den
letzten tagen und wochen dass ich null
risiko begegnungen habe ich weiß nicht
ob das irgendjemanden kontrolliert und
ich weiß auch nicht was diese app
tatsächlich noch mist aber wenn sie mal
schauen wir haben jetzt weit über
200.000 leute
herr grothe warnung haben die wiederum
ihre
kontakte informiert haben das findet den
ganzen tag statt
und in dem moment wo sie etwas wir ja
nicht hoffen auch selber mal einen test
machen der dann positiv ist dann können
sie auch ihre kontakte wieder waren und
sie kriegen ihr laborergebnis über die
wahren ab sofort sind wir nicht warten
bis ihr hausarzt oder ihre
gesundheitsamt irgendwann die
information gekriegt hat und das schafft
sie zu erreichen
sie haben auch ihr ergebnis in
sekundenschnelle sind alles ganz
wichtige funktion entlassen werden da
ist jetzt noch mal ganz kurz die frage
an dem digital experten welche chancen
haben wir noch mit dieser waren es
vielleicht ganz kurz und wo liegen
alternativen zu präzisen informationen
ich bin ganz sicher dass wir die
pandemie mit avaya schon 2027 in den
griff bekommen werden wenn die in der
entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit
weiterentwickelt wird wie es der fall
ist das ist nämlich das große manko
dieser wann habt das hat mir datenschutz
gar nicht so viel zu tun
das hängt auch damit zusammen dass die
meisten datenschutz entscheidungen gar
nicht von der bundesregierung getroffen
worden sind sondern von apple und google
und die haben das relativ restriktiv
gehandhabt
das ist der erste punkt der zweite punkt
ist aber dass man ursprünglich dachte
man hat eine app das waren jedenfalls
die experten darum um die
weiterentwickelt wird wie es in der
digitalen welt normal ist und dann hat
es unfassbar lange gedauert bis sie auch
nur kleine schritte nach vorne gegangen
ist und diese kleinen schrittchen wurden
dazu noch miserabel kommuniziert das ist
bei mir so dass ich aus persönlichen
gründen im herbst relativ viel in
krankenhäusern sein musste ich hatte
deswegen durchgängige durchgängig
wahnsinnig hohe zahlen also 18 risiko
kontakte dann gab es ein update ende
letzten jahres und seitdem habe ich
durchgängig nullrisiko kontakte obwohl
ich mich mein verhalten nicht geändert
habe und ich weiß wie vielen krankenhaus
ich weiß von vielen anderen dass die das
genauso haben
und das wurde gar nicht beziehungsweise
nur sehr eingeschränkt kommuniziert und
das steht dafür in der app für das aus
meiner sicht aller größte versäumnis der
bundesregierung eine sinnvolle
nachvollziehbare kommunikation gegenüber
der bevölkerung das war so zerfasert das
war so uneins da war so viel
inszenierung mit dabei da war so viel
parteipolitik mit dabei und zwar fast
von anfang an dass ich glaube da hat man
sich extrem viel vertrauen verschenkt
und wie kommen sofort zum impfen weil es
wahnsinnig viele menschen natürlich
völlig zu recht eine echte lösung des
problems ist zwischendurch noch mal die
frage nach den masken plötzlich sind
diese ffb zwei masken auch das volk
nicht vergessen sind retter in der not
op masken ffw zwei masken müssen die
eigentlich unentgeltlich sein wenn sie
zu einem solchen heilsbringer will man
fast sagen gemacht werden für die
bedürftigen ja die anderen mögen damit
ihren beitrag auch zum allgemeinwohl
leisten es gibt menschen die kratzt das
nicht
was ich finde das völlig in ordnung aber
diejenigen die sich das nicht leisten
können natürlich müssen die da
unterstützt werden frau bringt man was
sagen sie hilft uns auch diese fb2 maske
jetzt plötzlich ganz ganz viel mehr als
die selbst gehäkelte oder der
stofffetzen klar da sagt man ja aber
vorher waren die halt nicht da also die
fdp zwei masken ist eine gute idee und
definitiv besser hat eine gehäkelte
maske aber es geht gerade etwas viel
wichtigeres es geht darum dass wir
einmal ganz klar kommunizieren wir haben
ein problem mit den neuen varianten und
wir müssen verhindern dass diese
varianten hier fuß fassen denn es wird
viel schwieriger die zu bekämpfen und
frau schwesig hat es gerade eigentlich
auch sehr gut so zusammengefasst was
schwierig ist ist die inzidenz von 50
das erscheint mir ein bisschen wie ein
pflock den jemand mal eingeräumt hat
dass und das ist das strategische ziel
aber diese strategische ziel ist falsch
denn wir müssen ja ganz klar einsehen
dass wir es nicht geschafft haben bei
einer 50er institut noch eine kontrolle
zu haben denn wir haben sie mal nicht
gehabt und wir haben auch nicht
konsequent gehandelt als wir gesehen
haben dass die zahlen über die 50
steigen
sprich es wurde nicht konsequent
gehandelt es wurde halbherzig gehandelt
und zu spät
ich möchte noch einmal sagen wir sind in
einer situation wo wir jetzt die schulen
schließen müssen
restaurants seit wochen und monaten
geschlossen sind und auch die kultur
man hätte viel früher realisieren können
und müssen dass die sobald es einen
anstieg im exponentiellen bereich gibt
wie im oktober klar zu sehen war wieder
von der wissenschaft auch sehr klar
gewarnt wurde
da hätte man konsequent handeln müssen
und dann ist trotzdem ja die nächste
frage wohin und auf welche art und weise
und vor allen dingen mit welchen mitteln
man diese nuller incidents die sich
wahrscheinlich alle irgendwie wünschen
nicht nur in den träumen sondern jeden
tag bekommen und eines der
entscheidenden mittel dazu wäre
natürlich das impfen
und da sind wir irgendwie gefühlt auch
bei einem genauso großen bedürfnis dass
wir leider noch nicht befriedigen können
weil es auch mit dem impfen bei uns
nicht wirklich gut aussieht trödeltrupp
deutschland wer diese bilder von
impfzentren bei uns sieht weiß dass wir
ein problem haben
ausgerechnet beim einzig nachhaltigen
weg aus der korona krise gut läuft es
nicht
es ist natürlich ins ziel nach wie vor
zu wenig impfstoff dort die zahlen
sprechen eine klare sprache über 32
prozent geimpften israel über 7 prozent
in großbritannien nur 1,5 prozent in
deutschland dem land das den ersten
zugelassenen impfstoff entwickelt hat
während die eu noch auf dem impfstoff
basar gefeilscht hat haben israelis
amerikaner und briten einfach gekauft
wohl wissend dass teurer impfstoff
allemal billiger ist als dauer shutdown
nachträglich gesehen hätte man schneller
mit mehr geld verhandeln müssen um
produktionskapazitäten schon aufzubauen
das die firmen einfach schlicht auf
verdacht dann auch die fabriken gebaut
hätten
nach dem frühen impfstart anfang
dezember schmeißen wie bei exit briten
jetzt noch einen turbo an
zugelassen sind bereits drei impfstoffe
die vielerorts rund um die uhr verimpft
werden ehrgeiziges ziel mitte februar
sollen alle über 70 immunisiert sein
davon ist deutschland weit entfernt
wir brauchen ein nächstes großes
bedürfnis alle würden sich denke ich mal
jetzt gerne für einen solchen impfstoff
zur verfügung stellt oder ihn gerne
haben
wenigstens kennt nicht nur solche
nordrhein-westfalen stoppt jetzt die
impfungen in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen
überall stehen in zentren noch leer was
glauben sie wie viel vertrauen sie das
kostet dass wir nicht genug von diesem
impfstoff fahren man muss einfach noch
mal deutlich sagen
momentan haben wir zwei impfstoffe
zugelassen von zwei im grunde start up
unternehmen eine völlig neue technologie
verwenden wo die produktion erst
aufgebaut wird und das war uns von
anfang an klar dass das das dass wir da
am anfang noch nicht so viel impfstoff
haben werden deshalb haben wir die
ständige impfkommission den ethikrat ja
gebeten uns vorschläge zu machen wen
impft man zuerst weil wir diese
knappheit war also dass wir die bekommen
das war uns völlig klar und dann hat die
europäische kommission acht verschiedene
impfstoffe eingekauft weil wir auch
nicht wussten wer wird zuerst zugelassen
und die geschichte entwickelt sich
eigentlich sehr günstig für uns weil
nach dem 2 jetzt schon zugelassen sind
haben wir in aussicht dass in kürze zwei
impfstoffe von sehr großen unternehmen
mit riesigen produktionskapazitäten noch
zusätzlich zugelassen werden das heißt
diese phase der knappheit die dauert
jetzt vielleicht noch 68 wochen
und danach werden wir sehr sehr viel
impfstoff haben dann werden wir auch
sehen dass diese impfzentren voll sind
und das ist im grunde genommen ein jahr
nach beginn der pandemie eine riesige
erfolgsgeschichte dass eine also da muss
ich jetzt gern hofmann dies ist heftig
widersprechen
also ich bin ja gewohnt dass die politik
sich selbst lobt aber in dem ausmaß
finde ich schon eine frechheit wenn man
sich einfach nur die die bloßen zahlen
anschaut die die usa kaufen den
impfstoff aus deutschland im juli
die eu im november juli november das
sind unterschiedliche monate dazwischen
ist viel zeit vergangen und dann schauen
wir uns an wie die eu offenbar
verhandelt haben muss das kann man ja
auch sich daran anschauen wie die preise
sind natürlich brauchen die hersteller
geld und das zu investieren
also sind die preise sehr entscheidend
und dann sieht man dass israel vor allem
deswegen jetzt für alle bürger und
rinnen
bürger impfstoffe hat weil die etwa den
dreifachen preis bezahlt haben der eu
und mir kommt diese zahl so vor als
hätte die eu wahnsinnig klug richtig
viel sparen wollen weil sie im sommer
nicht damit gerechnet hat dass im herbst
und im winter eine große gefährliche
zweite welle kommt da hat man dann aufs
geld geschaut da hat man dann auf
parteipolitik geschaut und da hat man
dann darauf geschaut dass frau von der
leyen gut aussieht und die vier
gesundheitsminister aus deutschland und
frankreich und so nicht so schnell nach
vorne preschen und ich glaube persönlich
dass diese art und weise mit der
pandemie umzugehen daher rührt dass die
bundesregierung die gefährlichkeit
dramatisch unterschätzt hat der jetzigen
situation eine sache noch nachgefragt
karl lauterbach sagt das ja und das sagt
er auch nicht erst jetzt dass man in der
eu zu spät eingekauft hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt immer
noch wir können nicht mehr impfstoff
haben weil zu wenig produziert wird ist
das in ihren augen ein argument oder
wird nur zu wenig produziert weil wir
vorher nicht haben ich kann das ich kann
das im nativen nicht beurteilen ich weiß
aber je früher man bestellt desto
schneller können die kapazitäten
aufgebaut werden das ist ja nicht magie
was da passiert sondern wir haben
berechnet wie viele dosen werden wir
verkaufen können was können wir aufbauen
und da ist jeder tag den man früher
bestellt aus meiner sicht schon rein
unternehmerisch für diese unternehmen
einfach gewesen die sie hätte plan und
genauso ist okay aber genau so
formuliert es karl lauterbach und der
macht jetzt nicht den uninformierten
eindruck der sagen wir hätten längst von
moderner produktionskapazitäten und
firmen hier in europa und vielleicht
sogar in deutschland wenn wir denen im
sommer gesagt hat und wir möchten euch
wir haben im sommer genau das getan
während im august angefangen haben mit
mit piontek zb darüber gesprochen
ihr braucht es ja wenn das mit der m rna
klappt eine eigene produktionsstätte und
die wird jetzt aufgebaut in marburg in
die geht im februar jetzt auch in dem
betrieb wir sind mit fuhrwerk auch im
gespräch wir haben mit der ganzen
industrie die arbeiten wie verrückt wir
haben wir haben normalerweise ein
bruchteil der impfstoff
produktionskapazitäten pro jahr als das
was jetzt in diesem jahr passiert also
dass eine ware die noch mal den unterarm
menschen einkaufen juli und einkauf und
november erklären sie doch wieder diesen
unterschied die einkaufsmenge die kann
man ja kann könnten wir noch beliebig
steigern der punkt ist wir werden
wenn diese vier firmen zu lassen und
verlässlich liefern schon im juli august
viel mehr impfstoff haben als wir
brauchen um die gesamte deutsche
bevölkerung also viel eben jetzt doppeln
sich die argumentation kanada und die
usa haben fünfmal so viel wie sie
überhaupt bevölkerung haben bestellt
grundlegend doch dadurch auch nicht
schneller die produktionsschätzungen
haben anfangen die
produktionskapazitäten sind jetzt am
anfang gering und jetzt kommt ein
zweites sehr wichtiges argument hinzu
wir haben uns entschieden in europa
gemeinsam zu bestellen und zum beispiel
hat montech kaiser auch gesagt seht
verteilen sozusagen den impfstoff diese
produktionskapazität die am anfang so
gering ist sehr gerecht zwischen den
verschiedenen weltregionen die bestellen
also europa kriegt vergleichbar fiel mir
die usa andere hersteller aus anderen
weltregionen haben das anders
entschieden das ist in ordnung aber ich
weiß nicht ob uns das gut an sie selbst
er hat sich darüber gewundert dass die
eu sich so verhalten hat wie sie sich
verhalten hat und diese note
bestellungen oder notverordnung einkäufe
der usa in kanada
da fragt man sich als bürger natürlich
auch wenn ich was würde das für mich für
einen unterschied machen sie sagen und
argumentieren selbst jeder tag rettet
leben
dann könnte man auch mit einem not
verordneten impfstoff leben wenn wir
jeden tag leben retten können aber
stellen wir uns mal vor wir hätten eine
note zulassung für den impfstoff
gemachten dann hätte sich hinterher noch
herausgestellt dass wir eine politische
zulassung keine von der fachbehörde die
das exakt prüft und zu sagen wir lassen
den impfstoff ordentlich zu ich finde
auch die diskussion impfen wir nur
einmal strecken wir die impfung das hat
so viele abrisskanten zu sagen wir
vertrauen auf die qualität der
wissenschaft und die regeln die wir uns
gegeben haben
wir machen keine experimente mit unserer
gesamten bevölkerung sondern wir machen
eine ordentliche zu lange schon nicht
den genauen verfahren arbeiten wir und
deshalb ist sein die diese tage jeder
tag tut weh aber diese 56 tage die wir
dies dann am ende noch dauert jede
charlie ordentlich zuzulassen
das ist das vertrauen im stechen ich zu
ihr argument wie sich unsere
impfbereitschaft und verändert werden
mal irgendwo ein problem so aber sind ja
auch haftungsfragen und die sind
angesprochen vielleicht hilft uns
frieden frau schwesig wie sauer wie
früher eingehalten sind sie darüber das
ist eben mecklenburg vorpommern bisher
eine super im suff ergebnis gibt aber
sie jetzt ich weiß nicht den menschen
wann eigentlich diese zweite dosis
impfen können also ich bin total
enttäuscht was da gelaufen das muss ich
klar sagen und ich finde da sollte man
auch nicht um heißen brei herum reden da
würde ich mir wünschen dass frau von der
leyen frau merkel und der spannend sein
was schlecht gelaufen und jetzt
versuchen wir das irgendwie wieder gut
zu machen da gibt es jetzt vier
bemühungen aber wir hatten ganz klar
eine verabredung wir bundesländer
bereiten uns vor mit den impfzentren und
stellen alles auf das ist so wir haben
eine logistik dass wir in fünf monaten
allen in der bevölkerung ein angebot
machen können
die ist da aber wir können sie überhaupt
gar nicht nutzen weil wir nicht genug
impfstoff haben und es geht nicht darum
wann zugelassen worden ist da bin ich
sehr bei herrn braun ich finde es
richtig dass reguläre zulassung des
offener zu machen
das problem ist dass die europäische
union nicht auf alle impfstoffkandidaten
gesetzt hat und komplett für europa eben
auch bestellt hat und früh genug
bestellt hat das kostet geld das ist
auch mehr impfstoff als wir brauchen
aber das ist ja dann ein luxusproblem
wenn wir so eine situation haben und
außerdem können wir auch etwas an länder
abgeben die arm sind aber dass jetzt
andere länder viel mehr impfstoff haben
und wir nicht das kann man den menschen
nicht erklären und ich möchte ihnen ganz
praktisch erklären was es bedeutet dass
wir jetzt nicht viele tage im nicht
ausreichend impfen können bedeutet
einfach dass wir das später auch nicht
so einfach nachholen wenn dann ohne ende
impfstoff da ist im juli ist es zu spät
denn wir reden hier die ganze zeit über
die mutation die droht uns jetzt und
natürlich würde jede impfung jetzt
schützen und wir machen die erfahrungen
dort wo wir in den pflegeheimen haben
wir angefangen ältere menschen schon
einmal geimpft haben und trotzdem eine
infektion ausbricht weil man es nie 100
prozent verhindern kann stellen wir fest
dass diese älteren menschen zum glück
keine symptome haben nicht schwer
kranken das ist doch ein segen im
impfzentrum ludwigslust was ich vor paar
tagen besucht hat ist ein 80-jähriger
mann auf meine frage
ob er denn jetzt froh ist dass ich sich
impfen lassen kann in tränen
ausgebrochen und hat mir berichtet wie
hoch der druck ist die angst vor dieser
infektion und ständig stehen wir am
pranger die mps machen dies nicht machen
jenes nicht und das was das
allerwichtigste ist genug impfstoff zu
besorgen hat nicht funktioniert
und jetzt ist der impfstoff zurzeit so
knapp dass wir froh sind dass wir die
zweite dosis zurückgestellt haben unsere
erstimpfungen jetzt mit einer
zweitimpfung sozusagen abschließen aber
wir werden nicht so viele menschen wie
wir vorhatten jetzt in die impfzentren
einladen können
das ist sehr bitter es ist dies die
stunde wo sie jetzt wahrscheinlich als
neuer zuständiger für die impfstoff
bestellung denn es gibt ja
offensichtlich eine arbeitsgruppe die
regelmäßig tagt um noch mehr impfstoff
nach deutschland zu holen
gerne noch mal sagen können was hätte
besser laufen müssen und was machen sie
jetzt viel besser man das entscheidend
ist dass wir mit den großen
pharmaunternehmen die
impfstoffproduktion betreuen gesprochen
haben und haben natürlich auch gesagt
ich habe vorhin das beispiel event ein
werk wird aufgebaut ist
august begonnen worden geht im februar
in betrieb und wir sagen ganz klar dass
es nicht möglich ist normalerweise
dauert es fünf jahre so ein werk in
betrieb zu nehmen
das heißt wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit weitere produktion
aufzubauen das und auch weitere
vorprodukte zum beispiel in deutschland
herzustellen
das wollen wir auch aber das hilft uns
natürlich nicht den nächsten zwei
monaten wo der impfstoff knapp sondern
das hilft uns auf die längere frist
das heißt die nächsten zwei monate wird
diese knappheit noch anhalten
und wenn dann der zweite große pharma
hersteller zugelassen hat dann entspannt
sich die lage und das war aber allen die
zu jedem zeitpunkt bewusst und hat auch
nie jemand etwas anderes versprochen
das muss man einfach mal sagen im
dezember waren halle
ich hab' ich habe war bei unserem
uniklinikum hab selber geimpfte direkt
nach weihnachten und das war eine tolle
stimmung also ich alle freuen und
natürlich sehen schritt für schritt ist
dass der ausweg aus dieser krise aber es
war zu keinem zeitpunkt realistisch dass
alle großen länder der welt die 400
millionen europäer alle im
januar/februar geimpft werden können
also da müssen wir noch ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir nicht ein bild
stellen und uns dann sozusagen sagen
daran sind wir jetzt gescheitert an
einer aufgabe von der nie einer
versprochen hat und die nie realistisch
war die jugend aber es ist die
furchtbarste zeit es ist die
schwierigste zeit der pandemie und
offensichtlich ist das was sie noch nie
versprochen haben dann auch wenigstens
anders bei frau schwesig angekommen
sonst würde sie sich jetzt nicht so
bitter beklagen und die menschen haben
natürlich einen vergleich zu anderen
ländern und das thematisieren wir
thematisieren wir die ganze als einziges
land ist wirklich israel das die das
besonders gut gemacht haben das muss man
neidlos anerkennen die haben eine
deutlich höhere impfquote ansonsten wenn
sie in zwei monaten sich mit der frage
beschäftigen hat deutschland eine im
vergleich international sehr sehr hohen
kanada habe ich möchte wirklich
widersprechen
herr braun stellt es jetzt so dar als ob
völlig klar war dass wir am anfang
weniger impfstoff haben und der nicht
für alle da ist das stimmt auch wir
haben immer gesagt am anfang an gar
nicht impfstoff für alle da sein
das kritisiert auch keiner was jetzt
aber festgestellt wird ist dass andere
länder selbst die usa unter trump
offensichtlich besser und zügiger
eingekauft haben als die europäische
kommission und der vergleich und das hat
auch der das hat auch zum beispiel der
wissenschaftler vom biontech ja im
interview durchblicken lassen und ich
finde dass man das schon selbstkritisch
sich in der union fragen muss ich will
das mal gegangen oder aufhören traurigen
dorn und ich glaube ich glaube dass es
in jeder düsteren zeit immer ein
lichtblick gibt und ich gebe herrn braun
100 prozent recht in der frage dass wir
auf die richtige strategie gesetzt haben
kanzlerin und 16 mps waren sich von
anfang an gingen viele auch widerstände
einig wir setzen auf das impfen den
impfstoff und bis dahin hatte
schutzmaßnahmen und dieser impfstoff ist
jetzt der lichtblick und dass man auf
diesen lichtblick als europäische union
nicht 100 prozent gesetzt abgewartet hat
und gezockt hat einsparen wollte
ganz ehrlich ich werde nicht darauf
gekommen sei es dass sich die
europäische union so was leistet und das
ist jetzt auch kein kritik an die eu
da internationalismus die europäische
union hätte jetzt hier etwas für ihre
bürgerinnen und bürger tun können
komplett viel impfstoff einkaufen
frühzeitig geld ausgeben und wenn man zu
viel hat ist an die armen länder zu
geben was ist daran so schwer und das
muss man einmal will ich nur mal ein
sonst noch sagen zu hören trump also der
vergleich was die usa gemacht am unter
trump hat ein wort erlassen also quasi
einen kriegsrecht das dazu geführt hat
dass sie die vorprodukte die sie
brauchen für eine stadt im land halten
und ich finde da muss man irgendwo auch
mal ein bisschen das maß waren wir haben
in europa eine sehr sehr grundsätzlich
solidarische haltung innerhalb von
europa gezeigt und wir reden jetzt auch
darüber dass andere länder auch was
abhaben
deshalb sind wir ein stück im geleitzug
und haben uns nicht herausgenommen dass
wir sozusagen eine insel stellung haben
dass unser glaube das hätte uns auch
nicht gut angestellt argument ist das
sind nicht die argumente auf die
problematik die auf dem gesicht liegt
die problematik die auf dem tisch liegt
ist eine andere die ist nämlich dass wie
frau schwesig sagt wie hier scheinen
selbst sagt er war verwundert dass die
eu da so vorsichtig war die problematik
ist dass sie ganz offensichtlich den
impfstart verbockt haben inklusive der
beschaffung sie haben doch jetzt hier
die großartige chance der bevölkerung zu
sagen ja im namen der bundesregierung ja
wir haben den impfstoff verbockt aber
wir versuchen jetzt ist wieder richtig
zu machen das wäre doch eine
fantastische gelegenheit und das ist ja
nicht meine private meinung sondern der
gründer von biotech und frau schwesig
sagen dass auch und noch jede menge
anderer fachleute ein bisschen vertrauen
und ehrlichkeit in die kommunikation
reinbringen und nicht sagen wir haben
alles richtig gemacht wenn man so
deutlich spürt dass das nicht der fall
ist aber ein bisschen ehrlichkeit nicht
den eindruck zu erwecken als wäre würde
es nur an geld liegen dass man einen
hochmodernen frisch entwickelten
impfstoff denn es noch in dieser
technologie auf keiner wetten nirgends
auf der welt gibt ist kein
produktionsanlage gab dass es einmal
einfach nur hätte viel geld in die hand
nehmen können und dann hätte man
wundersamen vom ersten tag an davon
milliarden dosen haben können das ist
einfach eine falsche vorstellung sondern
wenn man mit denen spricht wenn man mit
der firma biotec spricht welche
anstrengungen die jetzt unternehmen
produktionskapazität aufzubauen wenn man
mit moderner spricht welche
anstrengungen übernehmen wenn wir mit
kür weg spricht da da ist gerade eine
wirtschaft die leiste dinge die hätte
vor allem ja jeder völlig und kommt das
denn das herrscher ihn als gründer von
biontech sagt er war sehr verwundert
darüber dass sie wie nie dass sich
verhält nicht mit sehr kritisch so die
pharmafirmen ich wundere mich über die
pharmafirmen und ich wundere mich
darüber dass offensichtlich bei der
verteilung von impfstoffen der charakter
einer pandemie verloren geht nämlich
dass das ein weltweites geschehen ist
ich verstehe völlig dass politiker in
der verantwortung ihren bürgerinnen und
bürgern gegenüber stehen die sie gewählt
haben
aber die pharmafirmen viele haben sich
im september zu einem communiqué
zusammengefunden und gesagt wir
verpflichten uns darauf den impfstoff
gerecht weltweit zu verteilen und sie
haben ja nun auch milliarden über
milliarden an öffentlichen fördergeldern
bekommen um den zu entwickeln
wir haben mit der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und der
kovacs der kobach säule einen
internationalen verteil mechanismus der
zweijährlich amt also meiner meinung
nach aus ethischen perspektive einer
weltweiten pandemie bewältigung unter
der voraussetzung auch oder und gern das
ja eine erhebliche soziale ungleichheit
da ist und genau dieser streit jetzt
hätte könnte hätte sollen europa
deutschland usw wir doch völlig
vergessen was in afrika lose von
vergleichen wir uns denn nur mit den usa
oder habe ja dass wir müssen uns doch
auch mit afrika vergleichen und auch
unsere verantwortung als westliche
länder sehen dass dort menschen sind die
vielleicht in zwei jahren mal irgendwie
nennenswert an das ist ein interessanter
impuls aber ich glaube die wissenschaft
hat auch untersucht das afrika zum glück
nicht so getroffen war bisher und wir
natürlich die risikoverteilung
einbeziehen aber dass wir sie völlig
vergessen und nur wir vergessen sie
jetzt vielleicht für eine sekunde mal in
dieser diskussion und haben sie
ansonsten denke ich nicht vergessen wir
nehmen den gedanken aber mit auf und
wollen an dieser stelle kurz luft
anhalten einmal zu unserer kollegin
online schalten zu diana zimmermann
nämlich das ist eine verrückte
diskussion und situation die es in
großbritannien gibt weil das land von
einer mutation zum dritten mal quasi in
einen strengen lockdown gezwungen wird
an den guten abend zu deal diana nach
london
die frage ist was weiß man bisher über
die verbreitung dieses dieser mutation
ja also die mutante b 11 7 die hat
insgesamt 23 mutationen deswegen spricht
noch eine mutante die hier neu
aufgetaucht ist dies zum ersten mal im
september festgestellt worden
da wusste man allerdings noch nicht wie
gefährlich sie ist ende oktober lag die
inzidenz bei 1 und prozent und das ist
in etwa das was momentan diese b 11 7
mutante in deutschland auch erreicht
irgendetwas zwischen ein und drei
prozent
inzwischen sind hier 85 prozent aller
corona fälle
diese b 11 7 variante und das liegt
daran dass die sich eben 50 prozent etwa
50 prozent schneller verbreitet als das
ursprüngliche virus und sich sozusagen
wie eine zweite pandemie auf die erste
obendrauf gesetzt hat und dass wir jetzt
hier sehen ist dass trotz des lockdown
der im november schon begonnen hat mit
regionalen restriktionen und jetzt seit
dem vierten januar wieder voll in kraft
ist entschuldigung dass ich die zahlen
eben nur sehr allmählich reduzieren und
wir momentan sehr hohen todeszahlen
haben und die infektionszahlen nicht
runtergehen weil das ding dich nur
infektiöser ist sondern dadurch auch die
rückführung der infektion fahren
schwieriger geworden
wir haben es erwähnt und du hast es
verfolgt die runde diskutiert wie hier
über das impfen
großbritannien steht tatsächlich in
sachen impfen sehr gut da wird diese
impfung denn helfen das virus in dieser
mutation in der mutante zu bekämpfen
wissen auch dass die wissenschaftler
schon
davon gehen sie auch bei b 11 7 es gab
kleine zweifel daran ob das auch für die
südafrikanische und die brasilianische
mutante so sein wird
da ist man sich noch nicht ganz so
sicher aber relativ optimistisch
momentan für b 11 7 scheint dass der
fall zu sein
und wenn wir uns anschauen ob es
bevölkerungsgruppen gibt die besonders
betroffen sind kann man das schon sagen
also es war ja so dass das ursprüngliche
virus nicht so sehr kinder ein gefallen
hat hatte man zumindest den eindruck und
das scheint jetzt ein bisschen anders zu
sein bei b 11 7 in diesen 23 mutationen
scheint auch eine drin zu sein die dafür
sorgt dass kinder er infiziert werden
allerdings kann man das nicht so ganz
genau deswegen sagen bei zu dem
zeitpunkt als ich bei 117 hier so
verbreitet hat waren zwar regionale
restriktionen überall in kraft aber die
schule waren eben noch offen so dass
sozusagen diese der ort wo sich das
ganze ding überhaupt nur verbreiten
konnte eben die schulen waren so dass
die incident jetzt in den schulen
relativ hoch war höher als bei der
ursprünglichen variante auf jeden fall
und insofern relativiert sich das schon
mal warum sind die briten ins
weltmeister oder fast im selben
waldmeister
was hat die regierung johnson anders
gemacht er habe erstmal eine
notfallverordnung verlassen und haben
diesen impfstoff sehr schnell zugelassen
also erstmal bei montech weiser und
jetzt inzwischen auch astrazeneca oxford
also den eigenen impfstoff auf den sie
sehr stolz sind von beyond haben sie 40
millionen und von oxid 100 millionen
eingekauft und haben zum heutigen tag
also gerade wurde verkündete schon jetzt
fast fünf millionen briten geimpft in
einer enormen anstrengungen das militär
hat die logistik übernommen überall wird
dazu aufgerufen freiwillig zum in fett
zu werden da kriegt man so einen kleinen
kurs und dann darf man impfen gehen
es gibt im ganzen land tatsächlich
eine große anstrengung dazu zu spüren
und in manchen regionen werden jetzt
schon die über 70-jährigen also nicht
mehr nur die über 80-jährigen sondern
auch schon die über 70 jährigen
aufgefordert sich impfen zu lassen
allerdings gibt es hier auch starke
regionale unterschiede also es gibt auch
gebiete in denen die über 90 jährigen
noch nicht geimpft sind
das wird damit entschuldigt dass es
relativ schwierig ist andy ranzukommen
an die reiten leute aber auch mit
lieferschwierigkeiten also ist der stoff
kommt nicht richtig nach und das führt
eben dazu dass jetzt großbritannien
beschlossen hat die in abständen von
drei wochen auch bis zu zwölf wochen zu
erweitern und hier tobt eine diskussion
darum weil eben der schutz nicht
derselbe ist aus israel gibt es da ein
bisschen beunruhigende formationen die
haben das versucht zu ermitteln und vor
allen dingen für das gesundheitspersonal
die sich natürlich nicht schützen können
ist die frage ob das wirklich in ordnung
ist denen zu sagen na ja ihr habt jetzt
die erste impfung bekommen aber jetzt
musste er leider noch abwarten
die anderen zimmermann danke für diesen
einblick in das geschehen in
großbritannien erste kurze frage zu
melanie bringt man verbringt man wie ist
ihre position und ihre haltung könnte
und müsste man jetzt nicht auch sagen
alle kraft in richtung impfen
also es ist richtig dass eine schnelle
impfung der bevölkerung sehr sinnvoll
ist was aber auch ganz wichtig ist ist
dass wir das vertrauen der bevölkerung
haben also dass die impfbereitschaft da
ist denn ein impfstoff kann noch so gut
sein wenn die bevölkerung nicht
akzeptiert dann es ist sehr schwierig
aber im moment haben wir das problem
nicht wir haben wir sind einfach zu
wenig impfdosen und ich finde dass die
diskussion dass gerade sehr gut gezeigt
hat und es spricht noch mal ganz klar
dafür dass wir die infektion die in
deutschland gerade stattfinden und wir
haben die infektionszahlen gesehen sie
sind immer noch viel zu hoch dass wir
sie wirklich ganz massiv nach unten
drücken
denn eins ist klar wenige infektionen
sind wie viel einfacher zu managen ich
kann viel einfacher eine kontakt
nachverfolgung durchführen
die deutlich und die unter einer beinahe
instituts von 10 oder darunter liegt als
bei einer hohen instanz die zahl ist
tatsächlich mal wenn diese variante
sicher durchsetzt und ich gehe stark
davon aus dass sie sich hier durchsetzt
dann haben wir hier
wenn wir nicht jetzt ganz klar
gegensteuern und den die produktionszahl
den faktor r
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir den jetzt
auf eine zahl bekommt von 0,7
da sind wir noch recht weit von entfernt
aber wir können da hinkommen und dann
steigen die zahlen sehr schnell dann
steigen die zahlen jedem gang bringen
sie jede woche um die hälfte
die frage ist ja wie erreichen wir dass
darüber diskutieren wir jetzt hier
fröhlich genau und haben oder auch nicht
mehr so richtig fröhlich weil man jetzt
wieder weiß wo es einschränkungen geben
wird und wir müssen in die schlussrunde
kommen sascha lobo der hoffnung sind
dass das jetzt die nächsten vier wochen
hinhaut und wir uns dann über eine 50er
oder vielleicht noch geringere incidents
freuen
also wenn ich ja ein braun höre dass er
nicht meine lage ist die bisherigen
großen fehler
seht ihr jetzt den piontek gründer und
frau schwesig zuzugeben dann flüchtig
ist es auch schwierig aus den bisherigen
versagens momenten zu lernen und dann
sehe ich nicht so richtig wie es in
zukunft gut werden soll vor allem weil
ein ganz entscheidender baustein von
fast allen maßnahmen vertrauen ist und
dieses vertrauen hat aus meiner sicht
die bundesregierung in ziemlich vielen
dingen verspielt unter anderem in den
schulen wo ich das gefühl hatte seit dem
ersten login
märz 2020 ist in den schulen strategisch
fast gar nichts passiert andere länder
haben
schnelltests und masken verteilt und
luftfilter installiert dann eine
vielzahl ganz zu schweigen von digitalen
plattform die auch wirklich
funktionieren und in deutschland hat die
kultusministerkonferenz das bräsige
gremium der bundesrepublik hat einfach
empfohlen die fenster zu öffnen in den
schulen und das finde ich katastrophal
ich glaube nicht dass wir das so schnell
schaffen und dann ist der ball wieder
bei herrn braun und wir fragen noch
einmal mit ihnen gemeinsam ob diese
instituts unter 50 bis zum 14 2 zu
schaffen ist und mit welchen maßnahmen
sie glauben das zu schaffen
also ich glaube wenn
und diese mutation jetzt nicht so ein
ding gerade fährt dann ist die tendenz
oder können wir das bis dahin schaffen
dann ist aber der punkt weil immer alles
sagen wir gucken nur irgendwie
interessiert das kaninchen auf die 50er
inzidenz natürlich quatsch dann kommt
die zweite aufgabe
sie bereiten wir jetzt vor dass die
gesundheitsämter in die lage versetzen
dann wirklich kontrolle zahlen wurde ja
eben gesagt zuviel diffuses
infektionsgeschehen noch die
gesundheitsämter müssen der lage sein
sagen wir verstehen das
ausbruchsgeschehen wieder wir haben
jetzt die chance wenn wir uns nochmal
alle konzentrieren und deshalb finde ich
ein teil der diskussion dann schwierig
weil die leute müssen doch jetzt merken
die zahlen gehen runter die mutation
droht wenn sie kommt haben wir ein
problem wenn wir jetzt uns konzentrieren
und alle noch mal wieder wird nochmal
energie wohl noch mal luft holen dann
sind wir der mitte februar vielleicht
unten und dann können wir das was wir im
sommer gemacht haben nämlich relativ
normal leben bei niedrigen zahlen durch
die unterstufe arbeit der
gesundheitsämter das können wir wieder
haben und das gibt uns die brücke bis
wir dann genügend impfungen haben auch
die briten haben wir eben gehört die
sind im lockdown obwohl sich mehr
geimpft haben
das hilft uns in den nächsten monaten so
oder so nicht die variante innenstadt
lockt da und die existiert einfach nicht
sondern wir müssen jetzt noch mal
durchhalten und was er eben aus london
auch sozusagen direkt nach welche
schulen waren es der verbreitung sword
am anfang der mutation und deshalb
dieser punkt ist wie gesagt haben
restriktiv auslegen das finde ich ist
etwas da müssen wir da müssen die
ministerpräsidenten und manche
kultusminister noch mal ein wort sagen
viele haben jetzt die präsenzpflicht
freigestellt in den schulen aber zu
sagen den nächsten drei wochen ist das
auch wirklich verbunden mit der bitte
dass die kinder wo immer das geht zu
hause bleiben damit diese verbreitung
der mutation durch die schulen wie sie
in england wohl passiert das bei uns ist
nicht gut ich habe in unsere kollegin so
verstanden und andere publizisten
übrigens auch dass das gar nicht so
richtig sicher ist dass tatsächlich das
besonders gefährdete orte sind die
schulen die kinder und jugendlichen aber
ich will die diskussion jetzt nicht noch
mal aufmachen das hat einfach was damit
zu tun dass nur die schulen noch auf
waren und man aber man muss ja manchmal
werden
diese sorge hat dass dass der
mechanismus sein könnte auch mal
vorsorglich danach handeln weil wenn wir
hinterher wissen okay es war so was hat
sich in deutschland genauso abgespielt
und haben einen großen fehler gemacht
wieder entschuldigen
ja das wird nicht funktionieren und wir
werden tatsächlich nicht noch mal
schnell zu fuß weh sich nach schweden
gehen können weil ich alle schon was sie
sagen wird nämlich bei uns in die zahlen
bisher durfte und bei den schulen lasse
ich nicht mit mir diskutieren
wir müssen jetzt jemand sage ich nicht
diese maßnahmen die herr braun sagt
längst um und deswegen ist es ein fehler
dass immer der eindruck entsteht wir
würden es nicht tun
ja da man sieht so schön an dem beispiel
dass sich das kanzleramt auf die schulen
eingeschossen hat aber besser wäre
ffp zwei masten für die bevölkerung die
arbeitswelt nach steuern wir haben heute
hier viele anregungen gehört bei den
grenzen dafür zu sorgen dass
grenzpendler mit schnelltests kommen und
vor allem natürlich der impfstoff da
sind viele dinge wo ich glaube jedoch
noch zu tun hat und julia bin genau und
deshalb wird mecklenburg den schulen
nicht ausscheren sondern weitermachen
weil sie bisher schon taten und sich an
die maßnahmen halten wir machen einen
punkt ich danke ganz herzlich in dieser
runde
wir sehen uns wenn sie mögen am
kommenden donnerstag wieder 22.15
gleiche stelle gleiche welle und
natürlich wichtig passen sie gut auf
sich auf läuten sie gesund und ganz
herzlichen dank für die debatte bei
markus lanz zitiert stephan
bis dahin tschüss vielen dank
[Musik]